ich habe grundsätzlich eine neun
millimeter dabei gehabt
da hat sich damals die schießerei
ereignet v leute sind für uns in diesem
extrem wichtig ich habe sachen erlebt im
rotlicht möglich es ist natürlich ein
sehr sehr abgeschlossener bereich data
business clubs sowie zimmervermietung
die hells angels immer mehr als bei
anderen mischten damit unwahrscheinlich
viel geld damit gemacht so großes elend
häufig reden wir ja auch über sex und
ausnutzung von osteuropäischen frauen
die leute greifen leider gottes bei
männern wie mir immer zu drastischen
massnahmen braucht ist wirklich so weit
gehen dass man mir tatsächlich keller
schickte mir ging es einfach darum den
fuß in die szene zu kriegen auf einer
höheren ebene
[Musik]